- [Narrator] Did you buy
or sell crypto this year
or maybe use it to purchase something?
Even as small as a sandwich?
If so that transaction might need
to be counted on your taxes.
- It's especially important
to talk about taxes
during this 2022 tax filing season,
because so many people
bought or sold crypto
during 2021 for the first time.
- [Narrator] The number
of crypto owners worldwide
nearly tripled in 2021,
growing from 106 million in January
to 295 million in December
according to a report by crypto.com.
For those crypto newcomers,
Wall Street Journal tax columnist
Laura Saunders has a warning.
- I think that the IRS has
a special focus on crypto,
because they're uncomfortable with it.
They see it as a kind of a
threat to the tax system.
They think it may attract
criminal activity,
money laundering, or tax evasion.
So the IRS is paying very special
close attention to cryptocurrency.
- [Narrator] Here are five
things you need to know
about taxes for cryptocurrencies.
First, how to report.
You'll see this question
on the Form 1040 right below your name.
Be sure you answer it accurately.
- If you don't answer the
question or if you lie,
and they later have a case
against you involving crypto,
it will probably be a lot easier
for the IRS to win that case.
- [Narrator] But once you check the box,
how do you know how much you owe?
To find out, let's look at how
the IRS defines the currency.
- Since 2014, the Internal Revenue Service
has classified
cryptocurrencies as property,
usually investment property.
That means they're not
like dollars or euros.
They're much more like shares of stock
like Apple or IBM shares.
- [Narrator] And like
income on stocks and bonds,
the law has different rules for short
and long term gains on crypto.
- If you've held it for a year or less,
it's a short term capital gain or loss.
If you've held it for longer than a year,
it's a long term capital gain or loss.
And those gains, if
they're long-term gains,
can be taxed at much lower
rates than say wages.
So the top rate on wages
might be about 40%.
The top rate on long term capital gain
on cryptocurrency would be 20%.
That's a big difference.
- [Narrator] The good news
is that capital losses
can be used to offset the gains.
Meaning you can pay less in taxes
for the money you gained in crypto
if you also lost money
investing in the currency.
But capital gains on an investment
isn't the only way people use crypto.
Some are using the currency to buy goods
like that sandwich or even a yacht.
- If you're holding your
crypto in a taxable account
versus say a retirement
account like an IRA,
and you use it to purchase something,
then you have a taxable transaction.
- [Narrator] This isn't a new idea.
- That's just as though
you were buying that item
with shares of stock, say
shares of Apple stock.
And just the way that if
you transferred the stock
to someone, you'd have to tell the IRS
and have a loss or gain,
the same thing is true with crypto.
- [Narrator] Also similar to
stocks, the IRS is trading
between two different entities,
such as from Apple stock to
Microsoft or in crypto's case,
from Bitcoin to Ethereum
are taxable transfers.
What we just discussed
applies to buying and selling
cryptocurrency and other tangible goods.
Where it gets trickier is if
someone is paid for services
in crypto, which happened
on a big stage in 2021.
The Mayors of both New York City and Miami
tweeted their plans to
accept at least one paycheck
in Bitcoin, plus more businesses
are offering pay in crypto
to attract younger workers.
- In that case it's compensation.
So you owe income tax on it,
but you also owe payroll taxes
such as Medicare taxes
and Social Security taxes.
After you pay those taxes,
it becomes an investment.
- [Narrator] But if the crypto is a gift
rather than a payment for a service...
- Neither the giver nor the recipient
owes any income tax on that transfer.
But when the recipient
ultimately sells the crypto,
they have to use the giver's cost basis
to figure the capital gain or loss.
It's not the value at the
time the gift was received.
It was the value when the giver bought it.
- [Narrator] And if that value goes up,
the recipient would have
to pay taxes on the gain
when they go to trade or sell.
So keeping a clear record is key.
Many people have what they
call hot and cold wallets
for security purposes, but this
also helps organize records.
- The cold wallet would be kind of
like your savings account.
You don't touch it.
The hot wallet would be the
one you're trading from.
And so you could tell the IRS,
"No, you don't have to
worry about the cold wallet.
Let's look at the hot wallet.
This is the one I was working with."
- [Narrator] Transferring
crypto between these two wallets
is a non-taxable transaction.
The IRS's rules on
cryptocurrency are evolving
as crypto itself evolves and
moves into the mainstream.
Some digital assets like NFTs,
don't have official guidance yet,
but many tax specialists
think they should be taxed
like collectibles, such
as art or antiques.
In that case, the top tax rate is 28%,
which is higher than the top
rate on cryptocurrency trades.
- My advice would be even
if there aren't rules,
don't think you can do
whatever you want to do.
If you don't report correctly,
the IRS may find out about it.
For instance, they've talked to judges
and been successful in
getting customer records
from places like Coinbase
that they can use
to match against people's tax
returns and generate cases.
- [Narrator] The tax deadline
for 2022 is April 18th.
For further tax questions,
see "The Wall Street
Journal's 2022 Tax Guide."
(gentle music)